So,
which is imperfect.
Guess what?
So is Westminster so's Whitehall.
So our political institutions,
I spent five years as deputy prime
minister in White Hall.
At the end of that,
I came out more antiestablishment than I
went in
because I saw a poll.
I still am by the secrecy,
the overcentralisation,
the of course I say this is a Liberal
Democrat and they lopsided and
undemocratic electoral system.
We have all of those things I think are
rubbish.
It's imperfect.
I want to change.
But guess what?
I'm not going to say in response to the
imperfections in our own political
institutions,
we're going to raise the whole lot to
the ground and walk off.
You don't do that in life,
do you?
When something is imperfect,
you recognize,
you try and make it better.
You work with others to do so.
But the idea that you can sort of wash
your hands of it because you don't like
its imperfections,
turn your back on it.
Pull the drawbridge.
I wish it away.
That's just,
I just don't think that is a practical,
uh,
response to the realities of the complex
and interdependent world.
And the complex and interdependent
European Union and the complex
institutions that govern it,
that we,
uh,
that we have here today.